everybody knows what a bully is
everybody's seen a bully operate now
when does a bully stop being an
when you break their knowledge when you
bust them in the nose
what have you made of the way that some
people have responded to Putin's
invasion of Ukraine on your own team
so before I joined the White House I was
teaching for the Marine Corps and at the
same time I was Moonlighting as National
Security editor for Breitbart I didn't
need the job okay Bannon saw me speak
somewhere invited me for a chat said
will you be my National Security QC guy
and I said I'm not really interested I
threw out a stupid number and he said
yes and that's when you go oh crap
so the reason I was in principle
interested in doing that
what 10 years ago was because of the
paucity I saw on the right of serious
discussion on Nash security because back
then you had two options if you if you
are a conservative in America you could
be a a crazy neocon saying let's invade
places and turn them into democracies at
the end of a gun barrel which is lunacy
right The Wolf of it is of the world the
Bush Administration or it could be an
isolationist and say screw everybody we
don't care uh anything beyond the
Pacific in the Atlantic is irrelevant
and they can all go to hell and I
thought you know you can be a little bit
more nuanced than that there is a pallet
of options and the idea that you can
isolate yourself from the rest of the
world after 9 11 or in the Cyber age is
just as stupid as thinking you can turn
Afghanistan into Switzerland so that's
why I did it today 10 years later it is
by magnitude's worse on our side it is
this is perhaps Beyond everything the
left is doing to this country in my
estimate open borders millions of
illegal immigrants fentanyl poisonings
on and on and on the economy for me the
thing that Galls me the most every
single day and I have people on my
Twitter feed you know get in touch with
the radio show who call themselves
conservatives or Republicans
and who say things
like Vladimir Putin is the savior of
Western civilization and a great
Christian and I'm going
you do know you don't have to be a cold
war child like me but you do know this
is a KGB officer who persecuted
Christians for a living and is a thug
and a murderer and people are saying oh
well he's justified in invading Ukraine
because because we provoked him
what what are you talking a nation like
Ukraine which was ranked 22nd in the
world in military power
is threatening a nation-ranked second
that has more than four thousand nuclear
warheads and you're telling me we
provoked it or Ukraine provoked it so I
am
horrified we had this discussion over
cigars last night I still don't
understand how anyone who has at least a
triple digit IQ can say the Russian
Federation and Putin are the good guys
so we have to answer your question in
brief we have a lot of bloody work to do
to educate people on my team about the
reality of geopolitics today and you
don't have to be a a geek about it like
me just the fact
well let's do that then because the the
interesting thing is that I think as you
say not a lot of people are educated on
either way what is the National Security
interest for this country
in supporting Ukraine so you can answer
that at a very prosaic level that is
intuitive and then you can go to the
geopolitical level the prosequence look
everybody's gone to school okay where
everybody's been a member of a club or
the Boy Scouts or the football team or
what have you everybody knows what a
bully is everybody's seen a bully
operate now when does a bully stop being
an when you break their
knowledge when you bust them in the nose
if you don't stand up if somebody
doesn't stand up to a bully on the
playground or in Eastern Europe the
bully proceeds to continue to bully the
vulnerable
the idea that whatever reason or excuse
is provided a nuclear-tipped nation with
11 time zones can break a taboo that has
been in place since 1945 in Europe which
means you must not aggrandize your
territory through use of force is
dangerous to every decent Nation every
decent person and if you want to go to
the wonkish level do your homework about
Vladimir Putin or any aspect I love the
bio lab stuff oh really the bio Labs was
the reason who's thinking built the bio
labs
the Soviet Union built the bio Labs it
wasn't Condoleezza Rice and George Bush
that built the you know bio Labs so get
a little bit of your factual uh ducks in
order but specifically a little bit of
homework who is Vladimir Putin Beyond a
KGB officer a silo Vicki a member of the
nomenclature's National Security
Enterprise
he's a man who's since becoming
president for 21 years has been giving
speeches about the illegitimacy of
Ukraine as an independent nation the
illegitimacy of the Baltic states the
illegitimacy of Poland as an independent
nation that all should be subsumed into
the radina into Mother Russia and you
think well those are the states that
border
Russia those are the states who are
fully paid up members of NATO so you
think this won't have consequences that
a man who has already proven that he
will keep his promises to use Force to
take territory wants to take Poland the
Baltic states he must be sent a message
you are not permitted to do that and if
you just want to be very pedestrian
about it he's a bully who has to be
given a bloodied nose
and said what would you say to those
people who provide a more nuanced
argument and go look
we have been an antagonistic presence in
that area of the world and Ukraine is a
buffer zone or a buffer nation and it's
rapidly becoming more westernized he
sees this as a threat to Russia and he
sees himself encroached on practically
all sides by pro-western Nations right
encroached by what what is the quality
of that if I want to use the language of
moral equivalency and the and the
terminology of the Kremlin propagandists
what is the encroachment it's the
encroachment of Western values of
representative government that's the
problem for Putin the Putin it isn't
we're an Empire
invading Ukraine invading the baltics
invading the I I work my job was to get
hungry into NATO when I worked for the
Hungarian defense Ministry we were
desperate to get back in why did we want
to be a satropy a slave state of a you
know a Western Empire no we wanted to be
part of what a member of a group of
Nations that is
part of the West that has representative
government that has free markets so so
again let's translate into prosaic terms
what is NATO what is the EU they're
clubs
nobody's forced to join the EU on that
nobody puts a gun to the prime
minister's head you know of Sweden says
You must join no you have to want to
join and you have to hit certain
membership requirements in NATO's case
it's very very easy you read the 14
points of the Washington treaty it just
says You must have a represented
democratic government and you must
contribute to the collective defense of
the club
okay well if Poland wants to join if
Hungary wants to join if Ukraine wants
to join why does another Nation that's
outside of the club get to have a veto I
mean imagine if what you're into movies
right like me you joined the BFI the
British Film Institute I was a member
when I lived in England what if your
neighbor said you know he's a bookworm
and he thinks he's a Luddite and he
thinks that movies are evil
would you be okay with your neighbor
saying you have no right to join the BFI
voluntarily you say are you on drugs
excuse me no I have a right to join any
association that I can meet the
requirements of so this whole idea that
we're an Empire
how did we gobble up these nations they
applied it was tough for Hungary we we
had to bump up our defense spending we
had to say yeah these are the things we
will contribute within a year to Nato we
will have a training center these these
are things that are voluntary
but another Nation that's outside gets
to stop you that's just nuts so the
obvious can't you know I agree with you
on a lot of this and stuff obviously but
they always counter argument to this is
if Mexico wanted to join the Warsaw Pact
would America just let that happen
uh that's a cold war context yeah right
so
America would do its downdust to stop
that
but there would be no moral or other
justification for us to invade Mexico to
stop that yeah we would cease to be
America if we said Mexico has decided if
there's a referendum if it's not some
kind of dictatorship if Mexico decided
the idea that what we're going to invade
you to stop you doing something you
voluntarily want to do we might use
Force
if what happened in Afghanistan happened
in Mexico what happened in Afghanistan
Christmas is 79. the spats now were
deployed went in and assassinated the
Prime Minister and then the tanks rolled
in and said oh Afghanistan is now part
of the you know the broader Association
friendly Nations right yeah so so you
know it's again what is missing with
these arguments is the moral content
it's the
um obvious fallacy of the Chomsky eye
Michael Moore moral equivalency that you
know the West is just another version of
the east or NATO is just another version
of a Warsaw Pact no it's not when when
you joined the Warsaw Pact
you were told to join the Warsaw back
give you one interesting example what
was one of the biggest problems with
NATO it's a wonky phrase called
interoperability we're all free Nations
and everybody had their own vested
interests and proclivities I'm a gun guy
we had at the height of NATO a dozen
different kinds of assault rifle for
troops right Brits had the FN America
had the uh M16 on the the belgians had
you know fnc why because we chose them
and they're also packed how many types
of gun did you have
and then how many types of uniform think
about this in across NATO everybody had
it was a nightmare we had DPM camo in in
England uh the the the French had their
kind of uniforms across the whole of the
Warsaw Pact you had the massive hats the
big epaulette why because you didn't
choose how to defend yourself you were
told by the friends Academy you were
told by the general staff in Moscow you
will have the t-72 you will have these
uniforms and you will have an AK there's
no moral equivalence there's no
qualitative equivalence to East and West
despite what tromsky and others would
have you believe and so what do you say
to those people who go look we're
funneling billions to Ukraine right you
look at what's happening in Orange
cities yeah look what's happening with
you know the fentanyl crisis look what's
happened with the unemployment look at
the debt how can we possibly justify
this yeah this is like the the Tucker
Castle the wing of the party here and
it's it it's intuitive it's it's a
seductive argument I mean think about
just I did the figures for my TV show
recently if you add up all the combat
deaths by suffered by the United States
since the end of World War II so that's
Korea that's Vietnam that's Post 9 11
Afghanistan that's out golf one and golf
two if you add all of the war Fighters
killed in combat for over 70 years it's
seven it's a hundred and three thousand
combat deaths
last year according to Biden's CDC the
Center for Disease Control in America
according to this regime's CDC 110
000 Americans were killed by overdoses
mostly from fentanyl so you got what
more people more civilians died in 12
months in America because of open
borders then died in 70 years of combat
in Southeast Asia in Afghanistan so it's
it's kind of like whoa but that's not
how politics works these aren't mute you
can't as we say in America you've got to
be able to walk and chew gum at the same
time just because we have a border
crisis doesn't mean that Ukraine is
irrelevant and doesn't mean that if we
don't do something about it now it won't
get worse what what are we going to do
if we invade the Baltic states I mean we
have an article for Britain the US is an
article 5 commitment to the Baltic
states to Hungary to Poland if they are
invaded by another Nation they are
obliged we are obliged to respond which
during the Cold War meant what nuclear
war
is are we prepared to do that or should
we do something about it now to make
sure it doesn't get to that point from
the beginning of this conflict 14 months
ago I wrote a piece I think it was from
Breitbart on my sub stack and when I
said we must stop this but not by boots
on the ground I don't want the 82nd
Airborne to be deployed to Kiev and it's
Kiev by the way guys okay
um I've said from the beginning we must
help them help themselves
and the argument I used to kind of take
the the legs from under conservatives
who say screw Ukraine is oh okay
is 1776 important to you
the Revolutionary War that created
America
oh it is you believe that America should
have split from King George and
uh-huh
what would have happened if Spain
France and Holland
hadn't supported Washington George
Washington
we are sitting now would be part of the
British Commonwealth damn those friends
no seriously so you're right so the idea
just to translate it I don't want to
fight for ukrainians because we're not
an Empire but to help them fight for
themselves
is what we should be doing but to your
first point
shoveling plain loads of cash to an
immensely corrupt regime let's look uh I
think he's in Europe of course it's done
so at the beginning I wrote an article
three things we need to do number one we
need to supply them with the means they
need to protect themselves mostly
ammunition they need artillery pieces
number two equipment which they can
actually use this asinine thing that
we're sending them Abraham's tanks
Abraham tanks of more than a dozen
different types of fluid to run them
t72 has oil and Diesel right ukrainians
don't know how to use haven't had the
training for f-16s or whatever else we
have stockpiles of Warsaw era Warsaw
packed air stuff in Hungary in Poland
the Czech Republic Slovakia give them
equipment they can use number two and
the third one is provide we are Peerless
America's ISR so our intelligence
surveillance reconnaissance capabilities
our satellites nobody comes close to us
give them the real-time Target data
packs so they can make the Russians
bleed in Ukraine that's what we do but
not pallets of cash not you know
billions of dollars in the space of one
year that's where I that's my nuanced
approach between the isolationists and
the sender 82nd Airborne
thank you